so no joke there is an actual CIA
document that was recently Declassified
which I'm about to show you that
discusses the topics of lost ancient
human civilizations and cataclysmic
events that happened on earth thousands
of years ago that caused those ancient
civilizations to vanish off the earth
and without a trace
thus answering the question why there is
so much mystery and unanswered questions
involving our true ancient past and it's
hard to even know where to begin with
this as this document is 57 pages long
and there's just so much to say about it
so give me a few minutes to connect the
dots on a variety of fascinating details
that are included in this Declassified
document and I will show you later in
the video exactly how to find it so you
can read it for yourself but the creator
of this document even describes the
Great Pyramid of Giza Egypt as an enigma
which yes it certainly is as even to
this day in 2019 we are unable to
explain how the Great Pyramid was even
constructed we can't even wrap our minds
around it's confusing internal design
and layout which indicates some sort of
purpose that is beyond our current
understanding as it shares absolutely no
resemblance to that of any other
Egyptian tomb ever found like I've
mentioned before no mummy was ever found
inside any of the pyramids and there are
a total of zero hieroglyphs inside of
any of the pyramids either another
interesting fact that I've mentioned
before is that not one single hieroglyph
found anywhere throughout ancient Egypt
shows anything related to a pyramid
whatsoever what a bizarre fact right the
Great Pyramid was even the tallest
man-made structure in the world for
nearly 4,000 years that was until the
construction of the Lincoln Cathedral in
England in the 1100s but keep in mind
that it's record height included the
central spire which no longer even
exists today as it collapsed just a
couple hundred years after its
construction I must say that I find the
Great Pyramid to be far more impressive
I mean let's not forget that it's built
like a three-dimensional puzzle made up
of some two and a half million stone
blocks that are stacked with
unbelievable precision nearly 500 feet
high and seven
50 feet wide at its base but the
Declassified file also lists other
mysterious sites as being enigmas
including that of Easter Island which of
course is located in the middle of
nowhere in the Pacific Ocean leaving us
many questions as to how people found
and settled on this remote island so
long ago Easter Island is most known for
the mysterious moai statues which are
the subject of much debate as to who
they were meant to depict and why and
also how were they created moved and
positioned in the way that they were in
the first place but what is perhaps more
interesting than that is just how
massive they actually are something that
most people are not aware of and they
can really only be appreciated when
compared to people standing next to them
this Declassified document details that
Easter Island was actually part of a
lost continent called mu or mu that was
said to have sank in the Pacific Ocean
during a cataclysm and Easter Island is
all that's left of it and I'll certainly
be discussing more about that later in
this video but I have to mention another
ancient site that is included in this
document that is listed as an enigma and
that is Baalbek in Lebanon if there was
one site that is truly an enigma besides
that of the Great Pyramid its Baalbek
and the foundation stones of the
Heliopolis that also make up the
foundations of the temple of Jupiter and
the temple of bacchus if there ever was
an example of a lost ancient
civilization that possessed some type of
relatively advanced technology keywords
they are relatively advanced the 900 ton
trilithon stone blocks are perhaps one
of the best examples of it and just look
how massive they are when compared to
people standing next to them and
although modern archaeologists and
historians credit ancient Rome for these
massive monoliths there is actually no
evidence to support it as the Romans did
not have the technological capability to
have moved or lifted these stones or
stones of this weights in fact literally
nothing from ancient Rome even compares
to the magnitude of these stone blocks
as the largest stone block within Rome
is the capital block which is only 53
tons and that is not to say that 53
tonnes isn't heavy but not when compared
to the trilithon stones which again are
tons apiece which equates to closer to 2
million pounds and were somehow lifted
over 30 feet up in stacked with precise
alignment and precision and this doesn't
include the several blocks located on
top of the Heliopolis which are
estimated to be at 800 tons apiece even
the smallest blocks that make up the
foundation are over 400 tons each and
there are many of them a significant
detail that is often overlooked is the
awkward fact that the Romans did not
even credit themselves for building the
foundation of this site or the
foundations of the temple of Jupiter or
the temple of bacchus which is truly
bizarre when we consider the fact that
the Romans documented everything they
claimed to have built upon the site as
evidence supports but they do not take
credit for the foundation stones
whatsoever what makes it even more
unusual as the distance that Baalbek is
from the Roman capital which is actually
closer to 1,400 miles away but it would
actually be significantly further when
traveling only by land and not by sea so
isn't it weird that the world's largest
and most impressive ancient monoliths
ever found which are allegedly from the
Romans are in such a remote location
that is so far from the capital and
again they didn't even take credit for
creating them in the first place so
although the Roman Coliseum as well as
the Roman aqueducts are unbelievably
impressive and marvels of engineering
and mathematics the largest blocks that
they are made up of our small multi-ton
blocks which are but a small fraction of
the 900 tonne 800 ton and many 400 tons
stone blocks that make up the foundation
of the Heliopolis and are simply not
comparable again these structures are
impressive but they do not demonstrate
an ability to move and stack 2 million
pound stone blocks 30 feet high with
precise alignment so if the Romans
didn't credit themselves for building it
why do modern historians say that they
did well it actually comes down to one
simple reason which is that they say
that there were no other civilizations
besides the Romans in that region so
therefore if it wasn't the Romans it
couldn't possibly be anyone else because
there was no one there before them so
therefore it was the Romans right but
then again these are the same
people that say that civilization only
began 6,000 years ago with the Sumerians
and these are the same people that
completely ignore the topics of the
Sphinx's water erosion as well as the
site of gobekli tepe which all prove
dates further back than 12,000 years and
of course I've discussed those details
in many other videos so I digress
now other ancient sites listed in the
Declassified document as enigmas include
tiahuanaco in south america which i'll
be coming back to later in the video
along with Easter Island as they both
tie into other fascinating things that
are discussed in the release document
but when I say documents it really is
essentially an essay that was put
together as a non-fiction book written
by some unknown person by the name of
Chan Thomas back in 1963 and was
published by Emerson house in 1965 under
the title the Adam and Eve story but for
some completely unknown and mysterious
reason or reasons this book was
classified by the CIA the Central
Intelligence Agency back in 1966 and it
wasn't made public again until 2013
thanks to the Freedom of Information Act
but it wasn't actually released to the
public until 2016 and was done so in the
form of a heavily sanitized document in
fact at the very top and bottom of every
single page it literally states those
exact words but listen to this and this
is where things get weird and will
really make you think so when I say it
was heavily sanitized the original book
was apparently 284 pages long and yet
the only released 57 pages in fact they
omitted entire pages altogether
for example the release file jumps from
page 7 to page 9 leaving us with no
answers as to why all of page 8 was
completely removed from the release
document and there's also no blacked-out
redactions of any kind found anywhere in
the 57 pages but the fact that it was
sanitized means that it was pieced back
together in ways that we are not aware
of so think about it like this
they released 57 pages out of apparently
284 so that equates to about 20% so the
big question is
what about the other 80% the significant
majority of this file is still
classified and there's no explanation of
why doesn't tell me that doesn't make
your eyebrow go up like what's that
about so yeah I find that really strange
and bizarre especially when you consider
the unbelievably bizarre nature of
what's included in the files that they
did release to the public but let me
just say up front I do not believe that
every detail that's discussed in these
papers are true or accurate surely some
of this stuff is just so crazy
and so unbelievable that it just cannot
be true I mean some of it sounds like
straight-up pseudoscience if I'm being
honest such as describing 1,000 mile an
hour winds and entire continents being
submerged in miles of ocean waves during
a cataclysmic pole shift event even
going on to suggest that the Earth's
crusts and will again in the future be
drastically displaced during a pole
shift event which according to the
document is caused by some type of
reoccurring explosion or disruption
within the Earth's core causing land
that was under the ocean to rise and in
certain cases certain mount chains that
are on land to submerge under the ocean
following this event which of course
scientists today will absolutely declare
as fiction and pseudoscience I mean the
document even states that there was a
race of blond hair blue-eyed people that
once existed on earth that were more
advanced in science than we are today at
least as of 1963 when the essay was
actually written no obviously some of
those details sound crazy so even if
various details described in this
document are exaggerated and false we
should not just completely dismiss this
document altogether because undoubtedly
there are certain things discussed in
here that are absolutely true as I'm
about to share with you and you might be
thinking yourself well they classify all
kinds of different things so this
doesn't necessarily mean anything but
come on think of all the crazy
conspiracy theories out there that
they've never classified that date back
decades and again to emphasize the point
one more time why didn't they release
everything in 2016 why'd they keep 80%
of it I mean there was a book written by
Charles Hapgood in 1958 that discussed
very similar information involving earth
crust displacement and that was never
classified but then again the details
that Jan Tomasz describes in this
classified document differs in a few key
ways and that may explain why what one
was classified and the other was not now
the document is broken up into six parts
and the first part is the author's
description of what will happen during
the next civilization resetting click
cataclysm and what it will look like
which of course mentions those 1000
Molinaro wins and continental flooding
as I just mentioned a moment ago
essentially illustrating the total
destruction to this era of mankind
stating that we will share the same fate
that our ancient ancestors experienced
multiple times in the past
essentially resetting us back to the
Stone Age having to start all over again
from scratch with our technological
knowledge and developments the document
specifically ties ancient civilizations
and religions together in multiple
instances throughout the essay for
example the author declares that Noah
Adam and Eve the Hindu god Vishnu and
the Egyptian god Osiris are all
connected by different individual
cataclysms that we set their
civilizations over the last tens of
thousands of years even going on to
connect Jesus with a Cyrus the
Polynesian God Terah with Zeus and
Vishnu claiming that it all connects
with the destruction of Atlantis and the
lost continent of MU and the destruction
of the Greek gods on Olympus alleging
that the roots of ancient stories
discussed in the Bible and religions of
Hinduism Buddhism and Islam all have the
same origin just explain differently as
they were passed down over several
millennia from culture to culture
religion - religion and I have to say
that I find it highly interesting that
it makes the connection between the
Greek gods Hindu gods and biblical
legends originating from the Sumerian
god kings from Mesopotamia let me give
you an example on that that I've given
in a prior video involving the depiction
of the Trident which is shared among the
Sumerians Hindu god Shiva and the Greek
god Poseidon is this really just a
coincidence because it seems to me that
there is a connection here that goes
further back that many would think even
look at the depictions of the cobra
snake a similarity shared among not only
Hindu gods
but Egyptians as well is it really just
a coincidence that they would
specifically position the cobra at their
heads although I do not know what the
true meaning of this symbolism was it is
certainly an interesting thing to
observe even consider the depictions of
battling massive snakes something shared
between both Hindu and Greek gods as
well and speaking of the Greek god
Poseidon who was said to be the creator
of the lost city of Atlantis this
document specifically discusses the
legend of Atlantis which of course was
shared by Plato in the Timaeus but
ultimately originated from the ancient
Egyptians from the temple of sais Egypt
where Solon had visited and accumulated
the information the document
specifically references that Cataclysm
as being the event behind the legend of
Adam and Eve as well as the destruction
of Atlantis the author also goes to the
extent to make the same point the Graham
Hancock has made when discussing the
topic of Atlantis on how someone's story
of Atlantis he received from the
Egyptians originated from the date of
9,000 years before that time which was
then 600 BC thus equating to the date of
11,000 600 years ago for when Atlantis
was destroyed or approximately eleven
thousand five hundred and fifty years
ago from the from when the author wrote
this essay but just consider that this
book was first written in 1963 and
published in 1965 well what a fantastic
point that this unknown person by the
name of Chan Thomas happened to write
about way far ahead of others I mean
Graham Hancock was something like 13
years old at the time that the author
wrote about this
it truly is fascinating that this
mysterious author was connecting these
dots so many decades before modern
alternative researchers were in fact
this essay connected the dots on
multiple details involving the Younger
Dryas climate catastrophe and again did
so decades before so many others which
of course I have discussed the details
of the Younger Dryas in many other
videos including details of the date of
the events that transpired on earth some
twelve thousand nine hundred years ago
and eleven thousand six hundred years
ago and this document is right
there are on that date when stating
11,500 years ago and again this document
was written actually about 56 years ago
it even specifies the rapid melting of
the Laurentide ice cap that occurred
suddenly at that time as well which of
course is included in the younger driest
climate catastrophe causing a massive
surge in global sea levels that happened
suddenly it has been suggested that the
deep freeze that the earth went through
that followed the rapid melting of the
ice caps during the Younger Dryas event
that the melting of that ice that flowed
into the ocean would have likely
disrupted the Gulf Stream which of
course plays a significant role in
warming our planet and perhaps that
could explain that deep freeze that
followed the melting of that ice so
could that be why they have found
flash-frozen woolly mammoths from that
period of time the document specifically
points out the fascinating mystery of
woolly mammoths that have been found
that were somehow flash-frozen even
while in the middle of eating food found
still in their mouths
as well as undigested food in their
stomachs and what an interesting detail
that this author pieced that together so
many decades ago but let me ask the
question what on earth would it take to
flash-freeze a massive animal that was
meant to thrive during an Ice Age this
is an unexplained mystery and when you
spend time reflecting on it it's pretty
astonishing so the next part is highly
controversial and many will deny its
possibility but the document describes
at this event which was a geomagnetic
pole shift that caused catastrophic
changes in weather as well as massive
changes in the Earth's crust all
happening within a 6 to 12 hour period
essentially a quarter to half of a day
and was the result of an explosion or
rupture inside of the Earth's core which
wreaks havoc on earth over the next six
days it goes on to explain that the core
of the earth physically shifts which
causes the magnetic poles to change but
it also causes the Earth's crust to move
over that liquid Inner Earth and the
catastrophe happens when the atmosphere
and oceans continue with their momentum
on their normal path thus inundating
continents with water and causing
unprecedented winds
in the atmosphere let me make this clear
mainstream science denies the
possibility of earth crust displacement
and considers this to be straight-up
pseudoscience so I am NOT suggesting
that it is true but I certainly find the
topic interesting and work and worth
looking at especially since Albert
Einstein considered the theory to have
merit and in fact he actually provided
the foreword on Charles hapgoods book on
this topic but let's consider what we do
know or should I say what mainstream
scientific and academic sources agree
upon on the topic of pole shifts which
is that the constant movements of the
molten iron at the core at the Earth's
core creates the magnetic field that
protects us from the vacuum of space
solar radiation and essentially contains
our atmosphere and according to these
same sources geomagnetic pole shifts
absolutely do happen we have evidence of
more than 100 examples dating back
millions of years and they say that the
last one was some 780 thousand years ago
but they also state that they normally
occur every 200 to 300 thousand years so
we are essentially some five hundred
thousand years overdue for some
mysterious and unknown reason they say
that when the next shift happens it will
likely not move the crust or cause
earthquakes or volcanic activity but
rather it will weaken the Earth's
magnetic shields by possibly get this 80
to 90 percent thus increasing solar
radiation significantly for a period of
time and causing what will be massive
failures and satellites various
communication systems and cause mass
widespread power power outages that
could last for months on end so let's be
real that in itself will be absolutely
catastrophic as we are now so dependent
on electricity and our supply chain gas
pumps won't work grocery stores will
empty in just a couple of days and even
the internet and phones won't work there
will certainly be civil unrest and chaos
if the lights are out for more than just
a couple days at a time you know I have
to say as someone that has curiously
followed the topic of poll shifts that
I've noticed a pattern among news
networks that cover the topic as they
always seem to downplay the significance
and how catastrophic a geomagnetic pole
shift will actually be for example they
never seem to match
how when the magnetic field gets reduced
it's going to affect weather patterns as
well as ocean currents which I mean that
in itself is going to be catastrophic
and I'm not saying that there is some
cover-up but anyone familiar with the
topic of cataclysms on earth knows that
for some reason mainstream science and
academia largely shun these topics maybe
they just don't want to freak out the
masses to things that are beyond our
control so they just kind of quietly
leave those things out
I don't know and just as a quick side
notes I wonder if there is some
connection between the pole shifts and
the pending discovery of Planet 9 which
astronomers are absolutely convinced
that it exists and has a massive orbit
of thousands or tens of thousands of
years and located far out from Pluto it
has a mysteriously large mass and I
wonder if pole ships could be caused by
cosmic influences involving magnetism or
gravity could Planet 9 and pole ships be
connected because there is already
speculation that Planet 9 could explain
the mysterious tilt and various planets
within our solar system but this is just
an idea who knows but consider these
other details that will certainly make
you think we know that we are overdue
for a geomagnetic pole shift and we know
that the next one is already underway
you may have seen headlines over the
past few months stating that scientists
were shocked to learn that the North
Pole has moved much faster and much
further than they had projected thus
creating an emergency to update GPS
systems throughout the world and as well
as updating runway numbers for airplanes
this is as recently as the last several
weeks but it really isn't that new as
these this also made headlines going all
the way back to 2011 and 2012 so the
pole movement has been going on for some
time in fact they've now identified that
the North Pole has moved at a rate of 34
miles per year and evidence going back
to 1990 shows that has moved more than
600 miles since then but what makes it
so alarming is the fact that the pole
shifts start slow and eventually
accelerate rapidly until it finally
flips so now we are seeing scientists
get surprised at its current
acceleration well this should
weren't a closer i buy scientists which
well actually in reality they certainly
are paying a lot of attention to this
because you may have noticed various
science articles circulating over just
the past few months stating that ocean
currents are now slowing down as we
speak
keep in mind that this connects to
shifting poles as ocean currents are
influenced by the atmosphere and the
atmosphere is influenced by our
geomagnetic poles and we know that ocean
currents affect global climate and
weather I mean it heats the earth it's
just one further detail that indicates
that our next pole shift is in motion as
we speak so the question is when will it
neva tably happen and I can't help but
wonder if that mysterious seismic wave
that was detected just a few months ago
back in November and you may have not
have heard of this has anything to do
with the movements within the Inner
Earth and pole shifts because scientists
detected waves that traveled around the
world at some 9,000 miles an hour and
have absolutely no idea what caused it
it was not noticeable for people around
the world the day that it happened but
seismic data shows that it occurred
leaving many unanswered questions
so with those unanswered questions aside
we must ask a big question here which is
why are we so overdue for a pole shift
and by overdue a half a million years
overdue what's that about well the
document claims and this is what makes
this document so unique in this theory
that the poles do a 90-degree flip when
it reverses and then within a six day
window it flips right back to its
original location thus masking that the
event had ever happened for modern
geologic geologic measurements so
essentially it's saying that this thing
happens every sixty five hundred years
which I don't know if that's true but
that is why we have no record of it and
think that we're long overdue when
really were not it's saying that seven
hundred eighty thousand years ago was
just the last time that we have evidence
of it but it keeps happening and this is
a key difference between the earth crust
displacement theory written about by
Charles Hapgood could this be the reason
why Qian Thomas's essay was classified
and hapgoods book was not I mean think
about it this document states that this
is happening every sixty five hundred
years and what happens the poles flip
right back to the original okay
Charles Hapgood did not state that and
although this certainly sounds
unbelievable I really and I would also
think by the way that we would have more
evidence to support if this was actually
true I mean every 6500 years but then
again we have to remind ourselves that
the earliest documentation of any
civilization we know about is the
Sumerians of 6,000 years ago yet humans
date back something like 300,000 plus
years and we only know about 6,000 years
ago and we know so little about that so
it seems to me that cataclysms could
explain why we have such a mysterious
past so again I'm not sure that there's
enough evidence to support that the
poles flip every sixty five hundred
years but I do find the sudden and rapid
changing of the Sahara how it went from
lush green to a desert wasteland
practically overnight and timeframes for
this when it was thought to have
happened is right around that 6500 year
ago mark give or take well combine that
with the fact that there is no current
scientific explanation for how or why
this happened to the Sahara Desert in
the first place so could it be pole
shift related so although there is
disagreement as far as how often pole
ships happen
why they happen or how devastating the
effects will be after they happen the
one thing that everyone seems to agree
upon is the fact that well they do
happen and that we are now due or
overdue for the next one but think of it
like this they ultimately occur because
of the shifting of the massive molten
iron core that our crust essentially
floats upon which by the way is the
reason why there is continental drift in
the first place which we know occurs at
a rate of about one inch per year we
also have earthquakes which although
some originate within the crust many
actually occur in the part of the upper
mantle which is liquid and when that
movement occurs it passes through our
crust and results in an earthquake so
why wasn't the sudden shift and that
liquid caused earthquakes and perhaps a
brief yet accelerated movement of the
continents ie some level of earth crust
displacement I mean if the 2011 Japanese
earthquake and tsunami which was a
magnitude 8.9 earthquake was able to
move the entire coast of Japan by 8 feet
in a matter of moments and I've
discussed this in other videos that's
something that should have taken about
100 years to occur with normal
continental drift but it happened all in
a moment and scientists were absolutely
stunned by that discovery and not only
did it move Japan 8 feet it also
shortened the days on earth by 1.6
microseconds which might not sound like
a lot but consider this it even changed
the tilt of the Earth's axis by six and
a half inches literally this one
earthquake moved the earth and this
isn't the only example of continental
crust movement from an earthquake I mean
take the 7.8 magnitude earthquake that
moved two islands off the coast of New
Zealand by five meters or over 16 feet
which is double the movements of the
Japan earthquake and at one point
scientists did not think that was even
possible but that was until they saw it
with their own eyes and had
documentation of it so if you think that
earth crust displacement is 100%
impossible pseudoscience you should
consider the awkward fact that virtually
all scientists once considered
continental drift to be pseudoscience
and that was as recently as just 100
years ago and think about how these
earthquakes would ultimately throw off
our geologic time line estimates in the
future for continental drift such as the
example of Pangaea and how long they
think it took to break apart well if we
weren't aware of the Japanese and New
Zealand earthquakes which like I said
the Japan earthquake accounted for some
100 years of continental drift in one
moment so it makes you wonder what other
earthquakes occurred in the distant past
that of course we have no knowledge of
that actually moved various regions of
land that led to inaccurate land
movement estimates for continental drift
in modern times so essentially
scientists are confused by the data
they're looking at you see it's examples
like this that should humble scientists
to realize that there's just so much
that we don't know we think we know a
lot but in reality we probably have all
kinds of data in front of us that's
throwing us off from other events that
we don't even know occurred so with all
that said could there be some truth to
earth crust displacement
I mean even if a majority of what's
discussed in this essay is just
exaggerated or false could there be some
truth to it under certain rare
circumstances such as with earthquakes
or when pole ships happen and are crusts
floating on top of that magma down below
our feet
could that play any part of the movement
of the crust in ways that we didn't
think we're possible because keep in
mind we've never even witnessed sub pole
shift we don't have the data to prove
what actually happens when it does occur
right something that is very interesting
to consider is that this theory mirrors
the legend of Atlantis and its
destruction which was said to have sunk
into the depths of the ocean it
certainly makes me wonder about the
nature of the rakaat structure which
i've proposed had collapsed and risen
again part of its geologic dome or
volcanic dome so it's striking
similarities salaah city of atlantis
aside which yes i will definitely be
making a follow-up video on the topic of
the recut structure and and atlantis in
the not so distant future but this essay
gives a specific example involving the
Gulf of Mexico and the Caribbean Sea
stating that they were both not under
the ocean prior to the last pole shift
and this raises questions about the
Bimini Road which is in the Caribbean
and is eighteen feet or about five and a
half meters underwater today there is so
much debate about this but was it
man-made was it a man-made road or is it
just some type of natural formation now
let's consider what the document states
about miu and easter island it claims
that it sank into the Pacific Ocean and
Easter Islanders what's left of it well
if that were the case perhaps it could
explain the irregularities in DNA
evidence that connects the Aborigines of
Australia to South America as I
mentioned this in a video two years ago
but there was a huge wrench thrown into
the known human migration process when
they discovered that mummies found in
South America have the DNA of Aborigines
from Australia this is a confusing
mystery even today among scientists as
they don't know how this happened but
that of course does not necessarily give
credence to that there was a continent
in the Pacific Ocean that allowed them
to walk across it to the South America
from Australia but keep in mind that the
author declares that the Peruvian Andes
were under the ocean prior to the pole
shift as well and this of course sounds
unbelievable considering that it is now
22,000 feet above sea level but isn't it
interesting to mention that scientists
agree that the Andes were once under the
ocean in the distant past
there are even fish and whale bones
fossils I should say found at the top of
both Andes and even the Himalayan
mountains all of which like I said are
now fossils with estimations to be many
millions of years old but why would
there be fish and whale bones at the top
of these mountains if it had not ridden
arisen so rapidly think about it if the
mountains formed so slowly over so many
millions of years when the fish and
whales have had time to not beach
themselves that's just something to
think about but the author includes a
Bible verse Psalms 46 is a supportive
example of the rising and falling of
continents as witnessed by survivors of
that Cataclysm and it reads therefore we
will not fear though the earth be
removed and though the mountains be
carried into the midst of the sea though
the waters thereof roar and be troubled
though the mountains shake with the
swelling thereof and actually the author
includes a few other interesting things
in the documentation from ancient times
suggesting as evidence that these
cataclysms were witnessed by people for
example the author also makes note of a
legend out of Tierra del Fuego in South
America of when the Sun was said to set
in the east and had risen in the West
also annotated are legends out of Peru
of the day that the Sun Stood Still as
well as legends from the Malaysian and
Sumatran Aborigines of the so called
long night and even makes note of the
interesting similarities among languages
from around the world including
Polynesian to Greek Egyptian Mayan and
even the Eskimos these details raise
questions and although myths and legends
do exist
we know that the originated from
something and it makes you wonder the
author even includes a direct excerpt
from Plato's Timaeus which of course
discusses the legend of Atlantis but
also illustrates how past cataclysms
have left us with no knowledge of our
ancient past which he claims our
ancestors were the most fair and noble
of all races of men that had ever lived
on the earth and for the sake of brevity
go ahead and press pause so you can read
that on your own but it is interesting
like what made them come to this
conclusion but you may also be curious
as to what's the very last page of the
declassified documents States quote a
little bit
knowledge can be a dangerous thing or it
can be a vibrant seed giving rise to
verdant forests and awakening sleeping
giants that is literally the very end of
the 57 page essay does this in any way
give a clue as to why this was
classified in the first place
basically insinuating that although we
could use this knowledge to help us that
the knowledge could also well freak the
hell out of humanity as a whole I mean
come on if people knew that there was
some sort of pending cataclysmic event
on earth that nobody could stop and
caught and would ultimately cause or
civilizations demise I mean maybe people
would stop going to work maybe people
would riot sir stop paying their taxes
or whatever right now I did some digging
on this chantamma sky and I quickly
found that he had published a book of
the same name in 1993 that was 232 pages
long so 52 pages less than the
classified version that was apparently
284 but this 1993 version was not
classified so it makes you wonder what
was left out of those 52 pages in the
non classified version but I mean what's
this about and what's the difference I
mean is this a way that Chan Thomas
found to make money while staying within
the classified limits of his previous
work from nearly 30 years earlier I
really don't know and I'm just thinking
out loud but why was this classified
from the get-go I mean how does that
even happen did the CIA show up this
guy's door and say hey we want to
classify this and in wood can they do
that
and what Chan Thomas have just gone
along with that would they have to pay
him money for his work you know I mean
like this is this is confusing like I
what's this about and again why can't I
find any information on this guy I mean
the most information you'll find is
what's included in the about the author
section of this essay which of course
was written by Chan Thomas himself so
this is certainly strange and of course
so many things in this document are
bizarre and unbelievable but again if
this was all pseudoscience which maybe
some of it is why would they classify it
then in the first place and then when
they go ahead and release it which was
forced by the Freedom of Information Act
they keep 80% of it yeah so that that's
that's really weird guys and so it makes
me think that you know
there is something here there's
something to see here and I think that
involves the nature of pole shifts I
think they know that the next ones
coming it's gonna be cataclysmic and
maybe that's the real reason why this
was classified as it had better evidence
than say other theories of the same idea
I don't know
now I'm sure that you want to see this
with your own eyes so let me quickly
show you exactly how to find this
document so you can discover that not
only does it actually exist but you can
read it yourself and the absolute
fastest way to find it is to simply
google the words CIA Adam and Eve story
which will bring the PDF version right
up at the top which you can click on and
view instantly or you can go to WWII gov
click on library and then click on
Freedom of Information Act and then
search the words Adam and Eve which will
then bring it up to the top so you can
click on that again why on earth is this
weird ask documents on the CIA's website
which was forced to be me made public by
the Freedom of Information Act I mean
this is a big question here now I also
recommend that you check out another
video by a youtuber who discussed this
document as well and that youtuber is
called suspicious observers I'm not
familiar with this channel as I haven't
seen their other videos but in this
video he raised some outstanding
questions about this document and
connected the dots on some fascinating
details that I did not include in this
video as there's just too much to
discuss so go check that out but before
I wrap this up what about the twelve
thousand year old comet hypothesis that
I've discussed in so many other videos
which there is an abundance of evidence
to support many have concluded that this
is what caused the younger driest
climate catastrophe and I certainly buy
into that so my idea and all of this is
that perhaps maybe both events happened
what if there was a cosmic impact around
twelve thousand nine hundred years ago
as has been suggested and then perhaps
there was a pole shift eleven thousand
six hundred years ago or maybe the
cosmic impact caused the pole shift to
happen maybe Graham Hancock and dr.
Robert Schoch are both right that
perhaps there wasn't impact but maybe
they're else
there also was plasma bursts from the
Sun which were able to torch the earth
as has been suggested by dr. Robert
Schoch
and during the last pole shift when the
Earth's magnetic field or shields would
have been significantly reduced to the
harm of the Sun so maybe both happened I
don't know what I can say is that talk
about total devastation if both these
events happen consecutively or even
twelve thirteen hundred years apart
because something happened twelve
thousand nine hundred years ago and then
something else happened eleven thousand
six hundred years ago what so the
question is what anyways I'm gonna wrap
this up this is getting very long I've
only covered a fraction of what's in
this document it's unbelievably
interesting so I recommend you check it
out
with an open mind I mean again it was
classified for a reason and they didn't
give all of it back to us when they did
declassify it so there is something to
see here clearly but anyways again I'll
wrap this up here many people are
wondering where have I been for last few
months go to my community tab under my
YouTube homepage so in fact I'll put a
link in like my pin comment at the top
but I explain where I've been what I've
been doing but subscribe to me on
Instagram I created an Instagram account
I want to stay in touch with everybody
more often and I also have a Twitter but
Twitter's pretty lame but anyways get
with me on Instagram and Twitter but
I'll be making many more videos in a
short period of time year I'm no longer
gonna put dates and time frames and when
I say I'm gonna make a video because
there's nothing worse than failing to
you know fulfill a promise but I have a
couple other videos in the works right
now that I think you're gonna find very
interesting so anyways I'll leave it at
that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight leave a
comments let me know what your thoughts
are on all of this and also hit the like
button and subscribe but I'll wrap it up
there take care everybody